[Music]  making drawings on land on quite a large  scale is something people can do for  thousands of years  [Music]  i'm simon beck  and i  make drawings in the snow  [Music]  it started as a bit of fun  but gradually it's taken over my life  a ballpark estimate of footsteps  about 5 000 steps in an hour  a big drawing  two hours measuring eight hours work  you're looking at forty thousand steps  [Music]  i started doing it as an easy  alternative to hiking at the mountain  when i went as an exercise  you're starting with a a drawer on a  piece of paper  or else you're drawing in your mind  just treating it like an orienteering  map  you're just going a certain distance in  a certain direction  determining distance by counting bases  it's a very physical exercise it's  equivalent to a long days walking in the  hills when you make one of these big  drawings  [Music]  i'm just about the only person in the  world doing anything like it  [Music]  you